[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien bonsoir bonsoir à tous bonsoir
pour ce retour sur diagonale tv ce soir
avec ce nouveau tournoi suisse nous
sommes le mardi 19 mai il est 20 heures
dans un peu moins de 12 minutes
maintenant on va démarrer ce nouveau
tournoi suisse tourne au suisse donc qui
va avoir très heureux on est déjà 41
inscrits est ce que ce soit on va battre
le record de participation c'est
possible parce qu'on n'est déjà pas mal
en général ça double peu près jusqu'à la
fin si on regarde le précédent tournoi
suisse tournoi voilà le tournoi à
mitzach et là on était 80 18 à 2 à 2
joueurs de la barre symbolique des 100
participants et bien c'est possible
pourquoi pas ce soir c'est possible donc
écoutez je vous invite à partager ce
tournoi autour de vous sur vos réseaux
sociaux
un petit lien rapidement sur votre fils
mastodonte sur votre film diaspora pour
ceux qui sont déjà libéré
et puis ceux qui sont encore prisonniers
bien sûr bombay par défaut évidemment si
vous n'avez pas le choix vous êtes
encore enchaîné dans les logiciels non
libres sur les plateformes privat trice
de liberté et bien vous pouvez partager
aussi
et sinon vous pouvez bien sûr aussi
table que vous n'êtes pas libérés vous
créez un compte sur mastodonte où on
compte sur sur diaspora sur l'une des
multiples instances qui existent du
monde libre voilà une pièce qui est un
logiciel libre
voilà comme mastodonte comme diaspora
c'est à dire un logiciel dans le code
source est publié disponible modifiable
copiable et sur lequel vous pouvez
contribuer donc en toute sérénité
puisque vos contributions qu'ils sont
amenés au code source
vous avez aussi un retour droit de
récupérer le code source
voilà donc on est alors on est 45 que
joueur c'est pas mal dit donc c'est pas
mal donc saluer et saluer cemga 2010 qui
en russe apparemment salua liénard salut
à cacahuètes 4 salua shachtman 56 qui
vient du morbihan salut à toi salua dur
c lients dur selanne salua no god no
masters le gold master d'habitués un
petit score contre no god masters je
crois on mène 6 et demi à deux ans et
demi est sanogo dno master est un joueur
attention qu'un joueur quand même assez
redoutable il a combien il à 2923 de
glee t-il pu se croire il a eu plus il a
eu plus jeunes ainsi la part frôlé les
2100 je vais aller voir sa page sur les
chess voilà revoir ad hoc sont holl holl
blitz à nant le muc fsil 2000
apparemment des sens où je crois que
c'était plus
meilleur classement atteint en 1998 donc
la barre des 2000 c'est l'objectif pour
nos gosses nos masters il peut il peut
espérer la passe et un de ces jours bien
sûr il va réussir la passe et no god no
master donc ce soir on est sûr sur une
mine aux échecs
voyez dans la description en mission de
la vidéo vous pouvez vous abonner à
imineo échec bien sûr il faut vous
abonner à éliminer aux échecs mais vous
pouvez aussi vous abonner à diagonale tv
youtube qui est la chaîne 100% niveau de
la tv sur lumineo c'est qu'on est avec
aussi d'autres émissions et c'est un
pool
c'est un pool multi multi échec
historique pour diagonale tv puisqu'on y
est avec tout le catalogue historique
avant 2016 notamment avant même 2015 je
sais plus mais presque toutes les vidéos
des banales tv dessus l'idée haut
historique sur imineo échec
voilà vous pouvez aussi donc vous
abonner à diagonale tv youtube diagonale
tv twitch ainsi que le mastodonte est
banal tv le fram à se faire des
bactéries ainsi que les réseaux
privateurs si vous n'avez pas le choix
ils y sont aussi mais je vous invite
évidemment vous créez un compte libre
sur des plateformes libres salua art
saleté slt salut à icap thibault
dans le chat youtube je veux jeter un
oeil sur tout ce qu'on commence à être
ça monte un peu sur twitch à un peu plus
de monde
il ya combien il ya de cas plus de 50
followers déjà sur ce nouveau compte 1
qui a été créée là à l'occasion
cependant je l'avais créé avoir en fait
j'ai créé longtemps mais je n'avais
jamais diffusés dessus et là je diffuse
en double alors donc alors j'ai petit
message bon ça c'est du russe je sais
pas lui en le ris voilà je peux pas lire
le rue saint-gilles palais et pas les
codes d'un virus qui est une langue
parlée par simple un toit l'alphabet pae
pae pas le même donc déjà ça complique
pas mal alors donc
[Musique]
alors alors alors salut à frédéric clôt
yart et âme aux prud'hommes on sort de
champagne salut anthony 3d salue donc là
je regardais la chance je peux jouer
hard et la tient là où j'en suis en
terme de blitz comme tu dis j'ai pas mal
chute est là depuis
bon j'ai fait des comptes repères fera
et donc j'ai chuté laroche et l'apparent
j'ai touché un palier à 2150 j'étais à
2275 mais j'aimerais lui et battre le
record qu à 2310 bon c'est faisable mais
il va falloir jouer autrement comment
avec le commentaire puisque c'est pas
simple en tout cas on essaie de s'amuser
ce soir 13 secondes c'est pas mal je
sais de on va essayer de voir ce que ça
donne
on est 52 il reste quatre minutes 36
secondes ça va pas tarder à démarrer ce
13e rang donc qui devrait durer
d'après ce qu'on avait vu samedi où on
avait fait entre seront aussi ça dure à
peu près à peu près deux heures au
niveau fort parce qu'il ya quand même
pas mal de 2200 2280 pour julien est de
111 g 21 22 et à 2241 superpower 51 et à
2236 jo bouchons en 2000 225 admin ch
est-ce la marque 2222
et puis on a un sargis nal tu n'as à
2353 c'est pas mal c'est pas mal du tout
alors si on regarde la page de la team
du l'honnêteté mais on est sans un peu
voilà le grand maître et le rolland qui
s'y inscrire il est là et loi voilà pas
encore participé mais cissé inscrit
peut-être qu'un jour il va participer
on a la petite île verte des monades tv
puisqu'on soutien ni chess voilà quand
vous soutenez leach s est un petit elle
qui apparaît vous n'êtes pas trop me
tiens voilà donc là aussi je peux que
vous inviter à soutenir une pièce bien
sûr c'est libre mais libre signifie pas
gratuit vous avez le droit de s est pas
assez pas obligatoire mais vous avez le
droit de bien sûr de contribuer à
soutenir
leach est économiquement avec avec un
petit qui un petit don est d'ailleurs
les pièces à 4,5 accepte les dons
bitcoin aussi n'accepte pas les deux
encore en ange une mais ça viendra
peut-être peut-être encore un peu tôt
pour la gym pour ça mais ça pourrait
être pas mal
salut à solène solène rigaud salut
solène bienvenue sur le tchat soulaines
rigaux on va vivre donc si vous
découvrez puisqu'il ya toujours des
nouveaux arrivants bien sûr sur internet
des nouveaux d'abord qu'ils s'équipent
et puis il ya aussi des nouveaux tout
simplement parce que il ya des jeunes
qui découvrent des jeunes des tout
jeunes
donc si vous arrivez on va donc vivre en
direct un tournoi suisse donc un
tournant 13 ronde système suisse ça veut
dire que c'est à chaque ronde on joue
contre des joueurs contre qui
qui ont marqué le même nombre de points
qu'eux
vous ainsi par exemple si au bout de
trois ans vous avez marqué deux points
et bien la quatrième ronde il thiès va
vous faire affronter quelqu'un qui a
deux points aussi voilà donc ce qui fait
que petit à petit ce qu'on le plus de
points finissent par se rencontrer c'est
sportivement plus équitable par contre
on est obligé ça oblige à attendre que
toutes les parties soient soit terminé
le tournoi est très fort il ya beaucoup
de 2002 2100 de 1000 milles 900 1800
voilà donc vous découragez pas essayer
de jouer jusqu'au bout
pour progresser il faut apprendre aussi
à perdre des parties à jouer contre des
joueurs plus forts on perd des partis et
bien c'est comme ça qu'on apprend aussi
qu'en s'améliorant petit à petit 55
secondes 54 53 52
ça va bientôt démarrer pour ceux des
gones à la tv suisse tournament
voilà allez je vais donner les liens
aussi sur twitch bien dans la
destruction
voila ca de m grâce à aller donc c'est
parti à l'est on enchaîne tout de suite
avec une partie face à jacou moto à les
d4 a été joué que 26 c 4 on va jouer
avec le camp bin cours avec ses 5
je fais c'est à la fois de faire
attention et de jouer assez vite b5 on
attaque le pion c4 en général ici les
blancs prennent voilà c'est un coup et
on sacrifier un pion par à 6 l'idée
c'est d'ouvrir les deux lignes ici pour
jouer à l'ailé damacy les blancs
prennent pas on a un beau jeu de toute
façon on va prendre
allez je vais jouer damas cinq échecs
obligeant le cavalier à revenir en c3 et
on va jouer g6 tout simplement et on
vous faisait cette tranquille
on n'a pas peur d'une découverte du
cavalier parce que le cas vivien 4
simplement bout de la dame il prend m6
on prend du fouet puis le pion b2 est
attaqué tout va bien pour les noirs
voilà donc ici on va attaquer le pion
par l'évidence d'un v6 il faut prendre
maintenant de b2 est attaqué
on comprend ces trois oui ça a l'air
bien de prendre ces trois ensuite sans
doute un simple coup comme x 6 à temps
parce que ma tour et active
je peux aussi jouer d'un bep 2 allée
d'un bep 2 à l'air très très fort
puisque sa taxe et trois sur échec il
n'y a pas moyen de sortir la dame à
cause de la tour si la tour vient en c1
il ya tout reprend 1,2 on récupère déjà
le pion avec une grosse activité noirs
ici et sur dame c1 on peut soit faire
trop prend à deux cas l'air intéressant
soit faire d'emprunt et tour prend 1,2
le ou l'autre dans les deux cas on a
l'air d'être actif
salut à daniele revis je vais suivre
nous dit daniel harvey bon je salue
habitent sur go pro salut bonsoir hockey
dame ses heures a été jouée alors ici on
peut faire trop prend 1,2 j'aime bien 3
de salaire très fort j'aime beaucoup je
le fais donc voilà tout dame prend tout
reprend et va tour b2 est extrêmement
active noté qu'on n'a pas peur de wayne
n'a pas peur du coup l'heure parce que
ce coup là on n'a pas peur du tout parce
que ce qu'on peut faire petit rock et
puis que la tourbe et 2 défend le
cavalier voilà est donc ici on va faire
échec avec une partie gagnante ici échec
croire 2 sans doute ici forcée voilà est
ici fois ci se terminer puisque la torre
fuite défend le cavalier
si tout reprend 1,6 mais sûr que la
vallée prend ici le roi bouger il ya le
fouquet perdu et tout est tenu de
l'autre côté
voilà donc cavalier prend alors la
maintenance et la catastrophe puisque
non seulement il qualité en moins mais
en plus le roi blanc est vraiment en
difficulté ici donc on va activer
l'atome est sûre c'est le coup naturel
activation rapide de la tour très bien
que les d2 c'est intéressant alors tombé
2 sans doute autour 1
la tourbe et deux salles est encore plus
fort je fais tour b 2 ça a l'air encore
plus fort antoine b deux cavaliers cloud
et 3d 3 était joué sa paire une pièce
puisque ya tour d un semble-t-il ici
ouais tour d un lecavalier maintenant et
perdu apparemment le seul coup des
blancs peut-être c'est douloureux 3 avec
le fou qui attaquent le cavalier à 6
mais dans ce cas je pense que simplement
je sors le cavalier de l'attak en jouant
cavalier c7 par exemple ah mais non
parce que sinon après il peut sortir le
cavalier donc on va bon on va prendre la
qualité on va on va prendre le
lecavalier et surtout prend on va
simplement prendre la tour on va
ramasser tous les pions avec une partie
gagnante au cordeau là ici on a la tour
la qualité en plus mais en plus on a
maintenant on va avoir un pion passé
sans doute puisque j'ai 2 ou r2 va
tomber ah non pas mal assez bien vu ça
très bon coup des blancs très beaucoup
des blancs ici bon mais simplement des
six alors on va activer le roi aprés
faut que je fasse attention à ce que ma
tour soit pas totalement fermée quand
même mais ça devrait aller suis pas trop
inquiet ici allez on va sortir le roi
jouault 6 maintenant pour essayer
d'ouvrir un peu les lignes les pions
prend
et tour ici pour attaquer le pion les
blancs défendent et ensuite par tour aux
5000 tours se réactive
voilà pour entrer dans le champ où il ya
du jeu voilà on évite de se laisser
enfermer la tour le roi est coupé pour
lui tombe à essayer de revenir
latéralement
oui alors ici semble peut-être joué 3
pts 6 dans un premier temps j'ai 5 c'est
pas mal on joue j'essaye tant pis on
lâche le pire on h7 s'il le prend on
prend entre quatre et six jouets f5
qu'il attaquera plus le pion et mon roi
surtout va pouvoir monter voilà donc on
va jouer simplement même page peut
obliger je vais simplement activer
matour allez on fait chèque
qui est vraiment stratégiquement
terminer ici ce n'est plus qu'une
question de technique crise prises et
c'est terminé ici on gagne autant mais
la position est clairement gagnante pour
les noirs c'est pas si j'étais le plus
précis mais ça c'est quand même assez
bien déroulé dans cette première partie
en tout cas merci à lui le suisse permet
de voir le stream
au fait pourquoi c'est pas la même
chaîne youtube que d'habitude nous
demandent de hugo bonne question
et bien parce que diagonale tv est
diffusée aussi sur une mine et aux
échecs il ya beaucoup de vidéos
diagonale tv sur lui nos échecs si tu
regardes notamment de toutes les vidéos
historiques
donc je continue à diffuser de temps en
temps sur une mine et aux échecs ou à
préparer des événements spécifiquement
pour imineo chef pour que la chaîne
continue d'être alimenté afin que le
catalogue historique diagonale tv soit
sur découvert par ceux qui le
connaissent pas puisqu'il a notamment le
il ya notamment le championnat du monde
kasparov kramnik de l'an 2000 sur ce
catalogue
il ya la coupe du monde de canal en 2000
en fait qu'il ya des étés
mais quand même des très beau très beau
témoignage historique en tout cas du jeu
d'échecs avec des productions des
gonades tv d'iliad ya 20 ans et puis on
trouve aussi tout le catalogue des
leçons avec ninon maisuradze et les
leçons pour débutants des modèles tv
ainsi que toutes les ouvertures analyser
avec que jean baptiste mullan des vidéos
qui date de 2000 e
2005 2006 2007 toutes les ouvertures ont
été vus à jean mathis moulin et formats
courts 30 minutes
la quinzaine de ça et tout ça c'est sur
une mine aux échecs donc bon voila voila
et sur une échelle qui est aussi
d'autres choses qui sont vraiment bien
pour les échecs il ya des documentaires
sur bobby fischer il ya plein de choses
sur les échecs sur une île au chèque en
plus de plus de 300 vidéos ou 400 vidéos
des bonal tv je sais pas le chiffre
exact
tellement il y en a voilà donc c'est
pour ça qu'il vaut mieux s'abonner aux
deux soûlard des news sur les échecs il
ya du banal tv sur les deux ok allez on
joue face à cech king ok allez on va
jouer avec eux quatre
on va essayer de rester concentré
surtout de continuer à jouer sur un bon
rythme des six ailleurs vos joueurs
étaient 4 qui avait laissé 3 allez je
continue avec l'idée h4
ces cinq des cinq étaient jouées tiens
ça c'est bizarre et je prends j'échange
ou f4 et bien ça empêche le roi devenir
ans et 7 et ça prépare un grand roque
avec échec
voilà qu'avec échec oui et donc là je
vous demande si cavalli place intérieure
par dahlia cinq attaques le pion c'est
déjà un peu délicat pour les pour les
noirs puisque qu'ils ont c'est celle qui
est attaqué
évidemment le fou ne peut pas apprendre
le cavalier puisque il est cloué ici par
par la tour oui
donc là je veux si je peux pas jouer
fois scène tient intermédiaires et le le
coup c'est bien sûr c'est qu'à les v6
qu'elle épaississe
la tour est attaqué et puis le le fou
maintenant on va prendre v8 et la halle
et les noirs père de tous en quelques
coups dans cette ouverture
tours est la tour est perdu voilà
abandon abandon des noirs ici il a
menacé après c'était de jouer cinq
cavaliers bouge je peux encore prendre
le fou avant de prendre la tour la main
c'était assez catastrophique merci à che
skin 13 04 alors là le problème 1 à
l'ouverture ici ça a été sans doute ses
seins que ce système peu rapide puisque
après la prise prises les changes des
danon des rocs leroy et on a vu que ça
peut aller très vite avec ce coup férir
4 qui empêche le roi d'alliance et 7
donc sur le grand roque il est obligé en
plus de rester au centre et c'est
gravissime et même à long terme puisque
les tours auront du mal à communiquer
ses points de parts hockey comme le jeu
souvent voilà donc après ses deux
premières parties il ya encore pas mal
de parties en cours pour l'instant
démarre bien ça nous change un peu des
démarrages un peu chaotique qu'on a vu
dans les derniers tournois mais bon ça
fait partie du jeu il faut accepter aux
échecs qu'on est des périodes aussi où
ça passe pas très bien mais ce temps le
début de tournoi se déroule bien on
marque deux points et donc petit à petit
on va rencontrer les joueurs qui ont
deux points donc on voit sur l'écran ici
les joueurs ici qui sont avec une toile
bleue ça veut dire que leur parti est
encore en cours voilà donc un combat d
maria par monty ça se met pas à jour
correctement
il reste encore 27 parties donc c'est ça
qui est bien suisse aussi on a un peu
plus de temps pour être tranquille et
commenté
entre les parties alors quand berset il
faut enchaîner enchaîné enchaîné bon on
est c'est un peu stressant on arena
salua haricots verts saluent haricots
verts voila voila je vais donner
l'adresse du switch aussi sur le sur le
tchat
noli caisse voilà salut à tous ça lui a
tu n'as mazet blot clos la nature à
salut à toi / twitch commence à avoir un
peu de monde sur twitch aussi attention
aux petits suisses way
et oui attention au petit suisse voilà
donc alors se forme donc 13 ronde comme
les parties et qu'on essaye de trois
plus de faut compter dix minutes par
partie environ ça peut être moins mais
sûre si les partis ne vont pas au bout
mais dans plus à deux parties plus le
risque qui est une particule yobou
augmente
c'était d'ailleurs au bout c'est à dire
adieu à 10 minutes voire au delà mais
bon voilà donc fois 13e ronde ça fait
cent trente minutes on ça fait à peu
près deux heures ça peut être un peu
plus que deux heures un peu moins
puisqu'on sait pas exactement le temps
que dure exactement les rondes
par contre entre oléron n'y a que 30
secondes de de relâchement parce que
c'est du blitz si tant est qu'on attend
déjà si on a finit tôt comme moi ici on
met le fait qu'ils aient 30 secondes
entre les rondes c'est bien ça permet
d'enchaîner tout de suite après la
dernière partie on y conviant des 77
c'est un très bon chiffre de
participation ce soir très très bon
c'est pas si on ira au sens peut-être
peut-être pas mais il reste du temps
quand les commentateurs 45 qui reste pas
mal de temps n'a fait que deux rondes
on peut avoir des joueurs qui rejoignent
le tournoi en cours de route encore mais
on battra sans doute pas le record de
participation de 98 haricots verts
pourquoi autant de joueurs jouent la
défense philidor avec les noix en ce
moment est ce dû à votre livre est
peut-être au in peut-être je veux dire
les joueurs sur internet
peut-être oui oui c'est possible
pourquoi pas
après c'est un phénomène de mode ainsi
une défense très solide la défense
leader après c'est un peu passif c'est
pas c'est pas normalement les grands
maîtres joue pas trop ça par exemple
s'ils ont besoin de gagner absolument
c'est pas forcément la défense qui
choisissent mais ça devenait comme un
parce que si les blancs sont un peu trop
agressif bien ils peuvent se faire
contrer violemment c'est parce que c'est
une défense très solide ya pas de y'a
pas de faiblesse côté noir défense
philidor c'est quand vous poussez le
pion du roi 4 et que l'adversaire joue
eu cinq cavaliers f3 avec consorts le
cavalier du roi pour attaquer le pion
aux noirs et les noirs jouent simplement
des six voilà c'est ça la défense leader
c'est ce coup des six qui est un peu
passif puisque ça laisse le faut et suit
un peu enfermé mais bon on peut ça peut
transposer dans une danse une espagnole
d'ailleurs la moyenne de transport et
transposer ça en espagnol donc c'est pas
forcément
c'est pas facile à jouer mais c'est sous
les doigts et c'est joli oui c'est très
solide
c'est très solide et ça peut faire
craquer des attaquants un peu trop
optimistes ça demande un traitement
solide aussi la défense est solide il
faut la traiter solidement alors que les
parties commencent à se terminer il
reste plus que huit partis en cours un
fort qu'à ce qui déjà se lamenta se
lamente commentaires dans l'internât bhl
il a perdu une partie apparemment qu'il
n'aurait pas dû perdre donc lors des
parties ici on a wado 2010 à 2209 face à
ce chan yan chang xian chayan 007 loïc
fournier 2165 qui vous fasse asie comme
atom 1898 par contre la position à lire
ici un peu bloquée
voilà ça s'est activée ça se met à jour
mais on n'a pas les tous les coups en
temps réel quand même parce que ça
demanderait sano trop de ressources
halliche est d'envoyer tous les coups de
blitz qui sont joués quand même assez
assez vite sur énormément de partie
puisqu'il n'y a pas que notre tournoi
sur les pièces actuellement mis sur ya
énormément de tournois qui se joue en
permanence
je vais vous dire qu'actuellement si on
jette un oeil je vais regarder sur une
autre page pour pas gêner le direct mais
c'est voir le nombre de joueurs
connectés actuellement sur l'île chaise
c'est tout à fait colossal puisque c'est
84000 quasiment 80 4900 joueurs donc là
ça y est on atteint les ça y est on va
passer les 85000 ouais on a passé les
presque les 85000 ont été agressés et on
les a passés 85000 joueurs connectés
actuellement sur les quais ce gala qui
se déconnectent y en a qui se reconnecte
mais c'est un chiffre tout à fait
colossal et ils sont quasiment tous en
train de jouer puisque on est à 34
milles de partie en cours pas tous il y
en a quand même qui joue pas alors
est-ce qu'ils sont entre deux tournois
est ce qu'ils font ce qu'ils se font des
puzzles les puzzles les problèmes échec
pour ce pour s'entraîner est-ce qu'ils
analysent une partie est ce que
simplement ils regardent les autres
jouer puisque on peut aussi simplement
regarder les autres jouer sur les
échiquiers c'est pas la vidéo mais c'est
chouette aussi
il n'y a rien de plus difficile que de
gagner une partie que l'on qualifie de
gagner oui oui c'est sûr c'est sûr il
faut rester très concentré pour gagner
une partie gagnante et ça peut se peut
se renverser bien entendu on est plus
que aller ça y est c'est fini on n'est
plus que de 15 à 16 on est seize on est
seize à avoir on est sept joueurs à
avoir deux sur deux on est plus que 16
et alors qu'on est la participation à
monter déjà encore on est à 79 joueurs
inscrits
c'est encore temps de rentrer je pense
que jusqu'à 9 même cette partie jouée à
jouer c'est pas mal pour entrer à l'est
alors que bf3 hommage aux qualifs 6
ces quatre bons joueurs et c'est ça
tient allez on va jouer un peu
symétrique cavalli un lycées 6
on va essayer de ne pas perdre trop de
temps en début de partie on peut jouer
peut-être des scènes tout de suite ici
profiter que les besoins de jouets 3
on a fait une partie récente sur ce
thème et on va jouer avec g6 problement
pas sûr on peut jouer à nantes et qu'il
va jouer prise prise qu'elle les prend
ce qu'on peut jouer c'est énorme je vois
budget 6g si ça a l'air très bien alors
il faut ces quatre pouces et 4 on va
sortir en attaquant le foot ou
simplement pour ne pas perdre de temps
le pouvoir reculer alors le fois reculé
ça c'est peut-être un peu délicat pour
les blancs ce genre de manoeuvre
j'ai l'impression que ça me permet
d'envisager le couffo f5 puisqu'il ya la
case d3 pour mon fouet parce que oui les
blancs ont choisi en développement on
peut peut-être un peu affaiblie sans sur
les cases blanches je sais pas on va
voir si j'arrive à jouer au foot est roi
il n'y a pas de plus d'europe possible
pour les blancs et ça ça va ça va leur
poser un petit problème quand même des
quatre a été jouée la prise à leurs
biens
et on va jouer ou g7 qui attaquent le
pion des quatre toutes nos pièces sont
sortis on n'est pas si mal ici
fo 3
alors on warocqué tout simplement pas
perdre de temps ici ce type 2 alors il a
rock et rauque et peut-être fou g4
maintenant ça a l'air très bon puisque
ça met la pression sur d4 et d5 semble
une erreur puisque ça permet cavaliers 5
et là il va y avoir un problème sur f3
puisque le fou est complètement à
l'ouest par rapport à au rock
en plus j'ai une très belle case
maintenance et 4 pour mes cavaliers donc
je prendrai peut-être ici du fou puisque
comme j'aimais pions sur blanc j'ai du
mal à reculer je prendrai certainement
du fou et ensuite je vais envahir la
case c4 qui va poser d'énormes problèmes
aux blancs tout en gardant une pression
sur le sur f3 on va voir
en tout cas il semblerait que les noirs
ici sorte d'ouverture avec un avantage
positionnelle assez nette
elle vous prend dans 17 et le jouable
puisque ça attaque bien sûr ici en jeu 3
ouais
donc là on va simplement continuer à
mettre la pression sur des 5
peut-être qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ici
il faut essayer d'augmenter notre
avantage d'un match d'un médecin qu'à
l'heure pas mal aussi d'un mec simple
continuer à mettre un peu la pression
ce côté là j'aime bien à 9,5
mais j'aime bien aussi le couturier
s'est kkr quand même pas mal aussi aller
en fait qu a laissé 4 quand même mieux
de ramener la pièce vers le vers le
centre on attaque le pion b2 on va faire
pour ces huit ici pour protéger ses 4
oui c'est vrai qu'il ya ça mais on peut
faire cavaler prend b2 avec du jeu quand
même mais c'est vrai que j'aurais pu
très vite ce n'était pas le meilleur
coût il est sans doute mieux mais c'est
pas mal si fine ok donc là on va prendre
le sein qu'on a récupéré deux pions pour
la pièce il ya toujours une pression ici
sur sur le cavalier c3 et en roi blanc
qui restent en difficulté alors
ouais
[Musique]
peut-être dame en 2005 alors cavaliers
en g3 ouais j'ai trop c'est possible
alors dans ce cas où la wii il faut il
faut que j'accélère dams et 2 comprendra
me prend surnomme prend part dans tout
reprend oui on va doubler les tourne
aussi tout reprend on va prendre tout
simplement on va jouer calais des trois
des six 14 secondes contre 30 gr c'est
dommage qu'on ait lâché cette pièce
bêtement sur un coût très bas atteints
on va jouer à 6 logique hein
oui on va jouer peut-être issifou x 3
tout simplement ses 80 jouer avec
cavaliers b2k et détroit va venir ici on
va sortir le cavalier là on va descendre
alors peut-être six joueuses 5 alors fou
des cistes peut-être ici on commence à
avoir un oeil sur sur le pion ici à lyon
joue avec b5 trice prise peut-être oui
alors là
simplement on va jouer qu'alexis on
monte le roi en seconde ça va on second
ça va aller cavaye h5 et là il ya un
problème sur f4 apparemment oui ça c'est
bien vu x 3 comme un échec on descend
tout simplement on va simplement revenir
ici pour gagner un peu de temps des six
on va prendre
pas de problème particulier ici échec
enjoué recettes
le fou n'a pas dix mille case cavale ces
six ans va ici pour attaquer le cavalier
sam lowry que on va récupérer une pièce
ici tout simplement
et oui on récupère la pièce c'est
magnifique
bien sûr et puis on va revenir avec
lecavalier
on va simplement jouer cavalier des 5 on
va prendre
ouais on va prendre ici on va jouer un
échec si il va pousser les pions
attention on va pousser leurs pions
on va avancer le roi fou b2o fo et 6,3
b3 on prend h4 bien sûr si on joue là
pour bien contrôler les cases
allez on pousse on pousse on avance
échec au roi ici on va pousser leurs
pions
on va pousser leurs pions
ici on va jouer food et 6,5 fois ici fou
et 6 5 4 3 pas facile la de savoir quoi
faire
il a pris ça à faire nul malheureusement
ça fait nul on va proposer nul on aurait
dû la gagner
si on n'avait pas je sais pas ce qu'il
s'est passé j'ai joué un peu trop vite
là on ne veut pas faire nul
ok donc si on revient à la partie
comment l'analysez un peu parce que
rares j'ai quand même raté un gars ici
donc l'âge et les noirs scolaires dont
j'ai une pièce de moi mais j'ai récupéré
quand même pas mal d'options et après je
vais récupérer quand je récupère la
pièce évidemment ça change tout
contrôler monde quasi si des six là il
perd une pile à il va perdre la pièce
voilà ici par la pièce voilà ça y est
c'est fait et là ça ça doit de gagner là
ici bon finalement établie et si c'est
pas forcément le plus le plus actif
refuge ou câblées g3 pour jouer dans le
iv c'était peut-être un peu un peu plus
contrôler un peu plus de cases qu'elle
ait des cinqs ouais j'ai pris la wild -
si je prends le fou voile et l'âge d'or
pour gagner quand même
ouais je recule ici oui il prend je
prends il revient là je viens ici au
dessin qu'il a il est revenu juste
attendre c'est là que je dois peut-être
poussé mon jeu va pas dû pousser le pion
tout de suite ici jouer sans doute joué
du jouet roy croit ces trois d'abord à
b1 ou b2
ce que je garde le pion ici qui empêche
le fou d'aller un peu où il veut et
comme car le fonds d'avenir ici le roi
blanc ne pourra pas attaquer ce pion qui
contrôle les cases blanches ainsi que le
fou qui attaquent la case noire ici donc
je vois du jour à b2 surtout bien roi b2
et puis après une fois que je joue le
coup à jouer en d3 disons roi c'est un
ou des trois d'abord puis ensuite trois
c1 b2b un jeu fait damer en plus ça y
est normalement avec ce pion je dois
pouvoir gagner malheureusement j'ai pas
réussi le coup il reste 30 secondes à
voir le début
bon mais j'ai quand même un demi point
est bon et je me retrouve un peu
derrière le groupe des trois points est
maintenant ils sont plus que six à avoir
trois points
allez 0 seconde c'est de rester
concentré quand même acheté un peu déçu
quand même par ces deux partis je dois
avouer et j'avais largement de quoi
l'emporter d'abord je donne une pièce
bêtement en oubliant de vérifier que
tactiquement simon couture celui de
marché puis après je récupère je dois
pouvoir gagner je la gagne pas donc ça
fait quand même deux occasions alors que
j'avais quand même une ouverture très
très favorable à l'or des 5
je vais prendre je rentre pas dans
l'avoine théorique djoukaev 3
je joue qu'à laisser trois ici je sens
mes pièces foulée cents coups à un échec
le petit rock les possibles ou à mai à 6
alors c'est roland c'est trop trop lent
ça peut pas être bon de jouer si c'est
ça peut pas être bon fou prend m6
qui on prend epci sous la la ça c'est
quand même très très surprenant on va
jouer tous rouvert alors maintenant
prendre ses cinq dont g8 voilà oui
d'accord 1 eh bien ça envoie du lourd
il veut attaquer sur la colonne ici
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
ça peut être ça peut être un plan nous
sommes je vous caler des quatre ans qui
le mans on va le dire à toi d'annoncer
cette halle est prise on va prendre six
tout simplement d'amd cette attention
tant mesdames prend lé 8 secondes il en
reste un du coup ça se fait que j'ai
défendus que j'ai des singes il me reste
autant en aussi peu de temps a laissé la
sap erp sap erp une pièce allez
simplement tour au cices annick qu'elle
ait des quatre sports tout reprend il
faut des 3 10 secondes ça va voilà
tourner si c'est bon on à consolider
notre pièce pas de problème oui donc ici
cavaliers c3g c3 ici si lecavalier bouge
malheureusement pour lui mais voit une
petite fourchette retour ouais bien vu
pas mal pas mal mais ça oblige saah sah
échange les tours et la finale est très
facilement gagné ici et là je pense pas
que je vais la rater celle là ça devrait
aller
ça devrait aller échec et abandon hockey
les noirs ont mis beaucoup de trop de
temps à roque et bien qu'ils aient
essayé de lancer une attaque c'était
quand même un peu olé olé de leur part
et on a encore gagné une partie rapide
alors au niveau du de la perche on est
bien on à 1,2255 de père parce qu'on a
un gros score bien sûr
ça va baisser quand le score va baisser
puisque ça serait étonnant comme un
conte finissent que avec des victoires
c'est parce que le pourcentage est fort
dont profère une grosse perf offerts
soit un gros pourcentage soit joué
contre audi fort joueur et réussir une
bonne perf sans forcément faire sens
pour ça on peut faire 60 70 % messieurs
vous face à des 2400 lots forcément mais
ça serait une grosse perf aussi donc
soit on joue face à des gros lots et on
fait un bon score
si on joue face à des lots moins fort
mais ce qu'il faut faire un gros
pourcentage 100 % 95 % 90 donc imaginons
que vous soyez un peu débutants
1200-1300 mais il faut il faut marquer
beaucoup face à des milles vous jouez
face à des 1000 lots et vous faites du
100% c'est possible si vous avez 302
points de plus ça va pas toujours mais
ça arrivera parce que là vous ferez une
croix ce père salua kasparov eurico qui
nous rejoint aussi sur le direct tapant
du labeur c'est pas possible ouais là
j'ai commencé avec une minute
j'ai commencé avec une minute énorme bug
assez pour ça qu'ils aient j'avais plus
de temps
un sas rare voir dans la vidéo alors
merci du signalement et c'est m'étonner
de plus avoir de temps comme ça huit
secondes j'ai pas du tout suivi
il ya eu un bug il faut leur porte et
halliche est ce ça donc merci de me
l'avoir signalé j'essaierai donc c'était
à la rente de 4 j'essaierai de voir ça
et je le signale aurait en tant que bugs
je crois pas qu'ils aient du bersac là
quand même en dedans le suisse ah ouais
donc c'est pour ça que j'étais j'ai
failli tomber autant alors que les du
coup ça peut expliquer pourquoi j'ai
perdu des partis comme ça aussi
dernièrement la durante peu trop dans
les suisses puisque depuis que je fais
des suisses là depuis je fais c'est
suisse j'ai perdu des points
je ne sais pas si c'est lié à ça est-ce
que ça m'est arrivé d'autres fois
peut-être on va voir j'ai eu un bug que
je vais aussi vite que lui
moi je sais pas je sais pas ce qui s'est
passé je sais pas mais c'est vrai j'ai
eu l'impression de comment ça se fait
que j'avais plus que huit secondes j'ai
pas l'impression d'avoir réfléchi autant
que ça aurait peut-être je regarde
oreilles je rentrerai je vais pas le
faire maintenant vous pouvez revenir en
arrière sur la vidéo peut-être et
vérifier si j'ai bien suivi j'ai bien
commencé avec trois minutes ou qu'à un
moment donné la pendule a pas descendu
d'un coup je sais pas mais pour vérifier
le mode berserk nous dit no god no mr
ben je sais pas y a pas de mode berserk
normalement dans le suisse pas de raison
de ap
non non puisqu'il ya ont marqué un point
en moins 2000 n'y a pas deux il n'y a
pas de ya pas de rage ou deux points ce
serait peut-être un bug de leech est ce
parce qu'il a repris le module des
partis et qu'il a ça peut être adapté
pour le suisse et puis il ya ce petit
gars c'est un bug c'est possible je sais
pas j'ai aucune idée mais vous me dites
qu'il ya ça je veux bien le croire parce
que je suis à chaque fois étonnés quand
j'ai plus de temps mais si c'est un bug
du système suisse ça expliquerait
pourquoi j'ai fait quand même des perfs
en dessous depuis que j'ai lancé les
suisses parce que justement ça
correspond à la période de mon arbre je
sais pas quand je suis pas trop atteints
sur la pendule
en général bon de façon générale c'est
vrai que déjà je fais pas ça sur la
pendule un général c'est vrai aussi mais
si en plus son homologue du temps
forcément ça m'aide pas mais bon non par
défaut je vais considérer qu'il n'y a
pas de bug mais vous ne m'avez signalé
en tout cas ça me ça va me pousse à
aller vérifier faut toujours vérifier
donc ça c'est vrai en général d'ailleurs
de retard par rapport à tout ce que vous
trouvez sur internet comme information
c'est toujours délicat parce que des
informations aux parviennent et puis
vous pouvez avoir tendance à croire que
c'est vrai mais c'est pas parce que
quelqu'un publier quelque chose que
c'est vrai donc il faut vérifier sur
internet pour vérifier à d'autres
sources mais abandonner des sources qui
ce qui saute aux références les unes les
autres
il l'a dit donc je l'écris aussi et
c'est vous a l'impression qu'il ya
plusieurs souces mais non c'est toujours
la même qui a publié et puis d'autres
qui ont fait le relais et ça finit par
créer des rumeurs c'est ça le problème
les rumeurs ça faisait fourni sur rien
une première information fausse qui
reprise amplifié etc
là c'était flagrant btoc ouais j'ai une
cuve minutes
mais oui qu'une minute depuis le début
un et curve et me dit j'ai une minute 8
secondes au début de la partie très
étrange d'accord pourtant les montres
suisses sont fiables en général
altruiste intéressés me dis ouais
j'avais une minute suite au but de là au
début de la partie qu'une minute dès le
début incroyable ah bah oui voilà c'est
pas du jeu au c'est un complot organisé
par jean baptiste non bâti c'est un jour
extrêmement fair-play maître
international
il faudrait pas faire des choses comme
ça puis je suis pas sûr qu'il sait qu'il
ait les compétences informatiques pour
les bidouiller le le code de leech s
mais en tout cas c'est très intéressant
ce retour parce que moi je vais faire le
jeu et remonter ça sur le github de
dulwich est allée des cas traités jouer
je vais jouer les cas les psy ces 5 et 5
à 6
mais si ça a été jouée je joue avec eux
des six cavaliers 17 g6 voilà il ya deux
écoles je peux prendre de la dame du
cavalier ci parce qu'il va pousser après
donc je prends de la dame parce que du
cavalier j'ai l'impression que je veux
revenir à la maison
donc je préfère prendre de la dame non
femmes bessette fait pression une
pression sur des cinq ça mange pas de
pain allez hop
reset way
peut-être c'est le monde joue aussi si
non non non parce qu'il va jouer qui a
blessé quatre bons coups très bien ok
donc maintenant on va jouer avec cavani
huit cavaliers c7 et on va peut-être
venir enlever cinq essais incluant dans
une très belle case en d4
et s'il prend du cavalier je comprends
du pion ça va chasser ce cavalier là les
petits ronds qui l'a fait donc il faut
jouer comme les baies 5
attention que je perde du temps ici
[Musique]
j'ai démarré la partie à une minute et
neuf secondes me dit année leur vie dans
la partie tout à l'heure d'accord sur ce
n est pas un ok donc alors est-ce qu'on
peut pas jouer ici qu'il faut pas jouer
cavalier des quatre quarts des cas tu as
l'air très bien
cavalier en b3 est possible le cavalière
s'est protégé par le par le fou ça a
l'air très très bien non je joue
peut-être joué dames c 'est tourbe et 8
tout simplement je sais pas
[Musique]
alors que tout tombe et 8 quand même
dans un premier temps ça marche pas de
peine mètres la tour sur la colonne ça
peut peut être mauvais ah les dames
c'est cette dame c'est celle qu'on ne
sache contrôle à cazaux 5 maximum de
fois il ya le pion il ya le fouille à la
dame tout va bien alors tour à 3 way en
coin intéressant maintenant je peux
jouer ou six parce que je protège ses
sets et je peux éventuellement faire
sauter ce truc là pour l'instant pas
tout de suite parce que si je prends il
prend du câble et s'attaque la dame
c'est pas très réjouissant en première
analyse
mais bon j'ai réussi à placer mes pièces
quand même dans un environnement assez
exigu cavaliers en e2 oui je peux
prendre en d5
allez je prends des cinq car très très
bon
et ensuite ici j'ai envie de faire
cavaler b5
je reviens attaqué la tour
ouais y'a clavier pts 6 attaque attaque
le pion tac le centre à mort très
important d'attaquer le centre aux
échecs
j'aime beaucoup mon club et les baies 5
à gaby bessy ce que le v6 weston coup
c'est un coup on va louer tour 8 tout
simplement on commence à prendre des
lignes c'est une donne le fou ça
m'arrange - je crois la ici ne viennent
pas trop trop
je suis d'accord pour récupérer le fou
ok donc là on peut jouer il faut g4 ou
faux bessette
euh je peux aussi vous de kabal et g4
pas mal bougé 4 a l'air bien mais sinon
il ya fou de cette terre pas mal aussi
larifou g4 aller j'aime bien ce coup
j'ai quatre jeux sans me fous de la wii
donc là je peux prendre et joué un très
beau alors est-ce que je prends pas
d'abord en e2 je prends d'abord et
maintenant qu'elle est des quatre
l'attaquent latour attaque le fou voilà
alors ici on va prendre ce fou c'est bon
de prendre les fouilles il faut prendre
les fous dame prend dans une transe pas
mal il veut venir ici
certainement donc on va jouer trois
fuites
voilà couvrir cette case adam prend 1,6
ça c'était pas ça c'était pas prévu
prend ainsi ce n'était pas prévu alors
il faut jouer il faut jouer il faut
jouer il faut jouer et je sais pas quoi
je veux jouer car il ya eu cinq attaques
le pion
dix secondes il reste de l'oci ouais eh
bien on va on va prendre en tout
simplement en f4 prison prend alors la
dame est reparti on va revenir en 5
on va jouer dans bessette peut-être pour
attaquer le pion ici échec on va
simplement descendre
ouais on a échoué car le temps j'allais
jouer cavalier m6 avec une pression sur
des 5
mais jouer bien joué non mesdames
principe c'était c'était pas prévu mais
c'était pas forcément très grave c'est
bon c'est vrai que le pion à saint
caprais est passé c'est vrai bon mais il
y avait encore dû beaucoup de jeu au
centre et son roi était et est quand
même peu faible donc gt gt pas encore
non je pense qu'il y avait beaucoup de
jeu encore c'est loin d'être fait
surtout ambit et c'est juste après il
fallait que je trouve un moyen d'activer
mes pièces mais bon j'ai pas réussi à
accélérer le jeu
les joues à lui
oui mais voilà l'intérêt du suisse c'est
que ça laisse souffler un peu
effectivement on peut regarder les
autres partis on peut faire le point du
tournoi ça où on en est alors que dans
le tournoi rhénan classique on attend de
rien il faut vraiment jouer jouer jouer
jouer en permanence
c'est le stress permanent c'est bien
c'est assez marrant je ne dis pas mais
c'est autre chose
j'ai pas reçu la lettre de temps l'aide
comme d'habitude ce soir nous dit harry
cover
oui alors c'est normal si vous n'êtes
pas abonné à une mine aux échecs il faut
qu'il faut vous abonner aux mines et aux
échecs et mettre la cloche ça si vous
voulez être au courant comme j'ai déjà
dit et je je diffuse sur twitch sur
youtube et sur mignot échec donc le
mieux si vous voulez être au courant
c'est vous abonner aux 3 voilà donc si
non alors à noter que j'ai fait une
interview hier sur le sur la chaîne de
jonathan jonathan qui fait une chaîne la
chaîne l'émission des jeux de stratégie
voilà mais si on est juste stratégie est
donc pareil sur les réseaux sociaux
diagonale tv mastodonte pharma sphère
twitter ou facebook
vous aurez le lien de cette émission
dure qui dure deux heures 45
voilà où je rends compte l'historique de
diagonale tb je répond à des questions
de jonathan y compris sur sur d'autres
sujets voilà je suis abonnée immédiat
recover mais est-ce que tu as cliquez
sur la cloche ce que abonnés c'est bien
être abonnés mais il faut cliquer sur la
cloche je crois pour être prévenu quand
il ya un live qui se lance voilà si tu
cliques pas sur la cloche terrebonne et
donc tu la verras la vidéo mais tu la
verras pas force sympa prévenu quand le
direct se lance alors qu'avec la cloche
vous êtes prévenus quand une nouvelle
vidéo est mise en ligne ou comme
indirects se lance c'est une
fonctionnalité youtube au sujet activer
la clause sur des chaînes qui me
plaisent
mais bon je ne faut pas l'activer sur
toutes les chaînes parce que sinon vous
allez vous allez
être prévenus en permanence qu'il ya des
trucs qui se lance
ça doit être intéressant comme
interviewer ou voilà vous pouvez la voir
quand vous voulez en plusieurs fois si
vous voulez dure deux heures sur 45
donc j'imagine et j'ai raconté quand
même pas le truc donc ça vous intéresse
de connaître un peu l'histoire de
diagonale tv ou mes activités par
ailleurs de que je mène ou que j'ai pu
mener vous auriez pas mal d'infos voilà
d'ordinaire je suis toujours bon ben ok
donc là bas tu l'as pas reçu bon
effectivement on ordinaire était prévenu
et là bon tu vas pas reçu je sais pas
pourquoi je ne sais pas quoi te dire
puisqu'elle était programmée depuis
depuis hier je crois si je l'avais
programmée de clients bon allez on a
trois et demi sur cinq
bon je suis un peu déçu d'avoir perdu
celle là parce que j'aurais bien aimé la
jouer jusqu'au bout j'aurai peut-être
perdu quand même mais ce genre de partie
que je regrette de perdre autant puisque
les reste intéressante des petits pièges
de porto où il était mal autant lui
aussi mais bon c'est moi qu'ils tombent
laurent fasciné a monté une cabale
contre tape pas dessus
ouais c'est bizarre ce coup tout à
l'heure si j'étais mara une minute 9
ouais c'est ça c'est ça vous revoir le
signal et ça donc je vais je vais le
signaler
parce qu'en plus c'est pas un bug qui
doit être facile à reproduire
donc heureusement que c'est enfin le
fait que ça a été filmé il va permettre
de voir que les développeurs vont
pouvoir voir exactement dans quelles
circonstances le bébé est survenu c'est
primordial pour opérer un bug
informatique
parce que là je sais pas comment ils
vont pouvoir reproduire le bug c'est pas
évident mais par contre s'ils voient
comment ça s'est déroulé ça va leur
donner une piste voilà dans un tournoi
suisse tel ronde contre hôtel joueur bon
ok allez de l'aipe 6
g6 allez on continue on insiste avec
notre benko elle lui non plus prend pas
cette prendre alors tout à l'heure je
veux si je peux pas jouer dame b4 ici
c'est pas mal de mme banon il ya 3-4
ok donc que le coup c'est peut-être
dames c'est cette plutôt que d'amener
cette année dame c'est cette europe
oui
donc peut-être fou bessette au final
l'idée de fouler cette c2 cédant moyen
s'est noyé 6 très tôt il essaie de
casser ce centre du clavier du bingo du
goudron les colonnes en a pas lieu voilà
on casse le centre âge que je vous
convie aux cinq qui allez prends pions
prend il ya un pion passé mais ça risque
d'être aussi un pion faible puisque fait
ou lors de vos tours 8
truite fief 400 au caire le signe tout
de suite à la mise à l'échelle et scène
tout de suite
cavaliers et 6 donc la tour 8 sans doute
fu f4 quand même on peut jouer qu'à les
17 attaques b6 protège au sel commence à
libérer le fou parce qu'elle est prendre
17 ans reprendra la dame sans doute on
laisse le cavalier on sait qui est bien
ce qu on sait qu il est très bien ce que
williams hank pourquoi le coup de
changer de place
serait pas très bien le 17 donc blessant
5 ok alors est-ce que je suis f5 ici
même cinq c'est souvent pas mal parce
qu'ils contrôlent à cazaux 4 allez je
fais f5 qui doit être un coup correct ça
contrôler la case cas donc ça empêche ce
cavalier de venir en quatre parfois peut
être intéressant pour dire il surprotège
dessins qu'il a raison
alors j'étais tous les goûts et 6 x 6
peut-être je vais doubler les tours 6
août aux recettes il va vous trouver 5
quelle est cette ça libère ma tour le
cavalier en plus défendez si ce qui fait
que j'ai pas trop d'inquiétude d'autant
que le cavalier lui il peut pas venir ni
en bessin ni en 4 m'attaquer des six
donc ça a l'air d'être très solide
maintenant je peux essayer peut-être de
lancer du jeu sur la colonne eux même si
je vois pas trop comment faire parce
qu'ils te recette est possible ouais il
revient ici hockey à ses intonations ses
intonations ici qu'est ce qu'on va faire
bientôt 4g pas mal ouais 27
blanc un problème parce que les blancs
sont attaqués ici et là ça a l'air un
peu délicat ouais mais surtout et 3 il
ya f4 claire de de gagner du matériel
non mince
oui et non ça gagne pas de matériel du
don incroyable ça il faut jouer à lyon
va faire puis on prend on va lâcher on
va lâcher un peu de deux calloc'h dame
prend le temps prend
je prends mes deux des quatre
je prends avec échec cavalli corrigé 5
je pense que soient très très bons
quel est vôtre on va prendre tout
reprend way ça c'est pas mal du tout
c'est pas mal du tout et je sais pas
quoi faire ouais ok bien vu c'est pas
facile j'avais échec la tour prend à non
il n'ya pas y apprend qu'elle cavaillé
bien joué ok bon je vous face à des
joueurs qui connaissent bien le gambit
benko apparemment là il m'a joué deux
fois la même variante
ce qui aliène pour l'interview avec
jonathan oui donc je vous ai dit vous
allez suivez diagonale télé la page
diagonale t sur facebook
le compte twitter le code mastodonte
lecomte fram à ce faire vous avez les
liens de ces comptes sociaux dans la
description de la vidéo si vous abonner
à ses comptes sociaux vous recevoir les
informations du journal tv et donc vous
allez vous allez sur la page d bonal tv
sur le compte des bonnes ltv mastodonte
dernier province faire voilà et vous
aurez le souligner voilà très simple
[Musique]
je pourrais jouer à musique un peu je
pourrais mettre de la musique mais je
crois qu'il ya après il prône le droit
je sais pas j'ai que les musiques libres
j'ai cotriade là si je me suis vu autre
chose je vais humaine tu vends des
problèmes de droits ouais bon appétit
ouais je mange un peu parce que sinon
j'ai pas mangé je vais je vais manquer
de sucre salua bouchon 65 vie qu il pas
aussi sûr au switch salut à vous il
reste quatre parties à la ronde suivante
ll faut reprendre ses esprits après une
défaite il faut deux défaites la loi est
ce dur
vont ils changer de variantes
six ou dix cas de dopage dans les échecs
je crois pas non je crois pas qu'ils
aient des cas de dopage n'y a pas de
prendre des vitamines pourront essayer
d'avoir un il faut prendre des vitamines
un peu de sucre avant une partie sans
doute parce que le cerveau ça consomme
quand même mais il n'y a pas en connait
on connaît pas de nom je crois pas
qu'ils aient dopage possible rien qu'on
puisse faire qui détériorent la sainteté
pour mieux réfléchir je crois pas allez
je crois pas que les drogues aide à
réfléchir donc ce que le problème du
dopage c'est pas le dopage en tant que
tel c'est le fait que c'est dangereux
pour la santé surtout près le fait qu'on
s'a milan 1 s'alimente spécialement pour
améliorer ses performances physiques
c'est pas mauvais en soi mais c'est
mauvais quand on le fait avec des
substances qui sont licites
mais après il faut comprendre pourquoi
elles sont licites ils sont illicites
parce que les qualifs trois jours il
faut c 4
du rock
ainsi ce toit 6,6 ou joey qu'à quatre
mais trois voiliers de b3 à vue qu'il a
joué à six ça peut être de jouer tous
les deux
c'est à lui de jouer
c'est un sport régime alimentaire sain
c'est autorisé voilà comme maxime alors
oui je sais pas si maxime et en régime
alimentaire saine j'en sais rien mais
oui je suppose que oui sinon je vois pas
trop qu'on me tiendrait alors trois
cavaliers de suite
alors que radio 2
khalili 6 kg 3
donc là j'ai fait ça pour libérer la
puissance de mon fou alors maintenant
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
cette roche 3
mais que le cnct leur mieux qu'à leurs
biens un car les cinq a l'air pas mal
parce que si j'arrive à faire sauter ça
ça va rendre les classements faibles
notamment le couffo à trois qui pourrait
venir échanger au centre libérer les
fous et s'il prend sans doute la prise
en 9 5 qui attaquent le cavalier a pris
aux 5 va tomber et ça ouvre tout le jeu
pour moi père de fou donc skype 5
carrières manière assez fort haricots
verts ouidah il a suivi un régime avant
les candidats apparemment oui sans doute
oui
si on or de jouer faux 6 alors qu'au 6e
faut prendre tout simplement prendre 6
un sacré défi en double et temporaires
mais après la prise en main cette il ya
eu 5 qui va tomber
donc là les blancs sorte de ça avec une
gros avantage ici tu me prenait 5 voilà
si je peux prendre
voilà tout simplement il va sans doute
reprendre
donc j'ai gagné un pion et foix iii
aussi peut-être
non il va y ait baissé 5 c'était sans
doute moins fort c'est une colère très
bien
alors dames où la dame c5 ça permet de
jouer ou des six pour cet ici c'est pas
ça doit être un très bon coup
allez les noirs sont en train de craquer
la craquage craquage des noirs ici
en quelques coups ils ont tout perdu
mais c'est vrai qu'à la fcm cavalaire
pénible mais je sais pas s'il est mort
pouvait pas sacrifier à leucate j'étais
en train de réfléchir à ça ok quatre
intermédiaires d'un v6 vous prend la
fuite
un f3 donc je vais simplement prendre et
jouer juste
alors non merci 3 ou d'hommes des trois
dames des six
ça a l'air bien aller d'amd 6
alors cavaliers un g4 donc là on peut
jouer le 3 certainement mais je peux
aussi jouer
voilà me 9,3 seigneurie f3
il y en avait autant ok alors y at-il
vraiment une sorte de complexe
d'infériorité des amis vis-à-vis des gmi
où il suit les jeunes une rumeur selon
toi il peut y avoir des complexes
d'infériorité quel que soit le quel que
soit le niveau du joueur si si vous
jouez contre onze joueurs qui à 100
points de plus que vous classement ou de
cinq points de plus bon mais c'est
normal de que canfin ça va dépendre des
joueurs aussi mais il ya des joueurs qui
vont se sentir en extériorité qui vont
pas jouer pareil que contre joueur qui a
un classement un peu près similaire au
leur on sait pas si on peut appeler ça
de la favorite et c'est plutôt un
mécanisme de prudence je le dirai je
sais pas
alors il ya pas plus tôt film qui vous
mais là il est pas bien apparemment
parce qu'il a une qualité en moins même
si elles y ont passé quand même qui peut
lui donner quelques chances
ouais amel a réussi à s'en sortir il a
réussi à le piquer le bon ça ça gagne
facilement pour les blancs mais à quel
moment il a réussi à lui piquer le ici
anika war à oui ils ont craqué non il
fallait qu'ils sacrifient de carrie
contre le pion il fallait pas envie
d'accord ok mais non on fait n'importe
quoi il fallait donner le cavaly
contrôle pions et peut-être avec la tour
contre les deux pièces trois pions
contre deux sur l'ale peut-être sa ferme
où je pense des rivalités entre les
joueurs français de haut niveau à bueil
forcément il ya des rivalités bien sûr
mais bon en général les joueurs français
de haut niveau se respecte tous se
connaissent bien
c'est sûr je sais pas je bois je vais
pas jusqu'à dire sont tous amis mais non
je dirais pas ça mais je veux dire oui
on en a pris il ya des rivalités comme
dans tous les sports peuvent être unis
comme un sportif lié à d'autres
phénomènes alors hugo il fut 31e je fais
n'importe quoi mais le loyer mais hugo
le trop long et difficile aussi c'est un
tournoi de quand même il ya quand même
pas mal de bons joueurs à 2002 2005 2006
et quand même tournoi difficile on est
c'est pas mal c'est un des meilleurs
scores de participation pour l'instant
c'est bien donc alors on est à quatre et
demi sur / / / / 7
ça va pour l'instant même si les deux
bulles là ça fait un peu mal mais ils
m'ont
je pense que l'erreur j'ai fait ci joué
deux fois la même ouverture après
l'avoir perdu j'aurais dû changer
peut-être perdu quand même aller 2023 on
joue face à tours c'est lent on n'a pas
de score contre dur c'est lent alors que
4 2,5 qu'avec trois sur les pièces allez
je vais jouer fou c4 est ici j'ai
plusieurs options je vous colle et g5 et
je jouais détroit je veux jouer à la
maxime je compte maximy jour être comme
ça rock c3
nous mettrons sur le fond de la salle si
ça a été joué juhan 3
à 5 5 c'est bizarre 5 c'est vraiment
bizarre toi hein
moi général de ce type de partie on joue
pas à 5 ans joue à 6b 5
c'est un peu l'espagnole fouet 6
ce que j'accepte d'échangés ce faux pas
non je garde mon fou fou et 3000 à
demain 17 ça peut faire peur ça parce
que des fois on va y avoir une prise ici
mais mes bons n'ont pas non plus laisser
impressionner
ça
c'est important à chaque secousse et 5
parce que quand même il vise haut morvan
et je n'ai pas eu peur assuré cavaliers
h7
ouais dans ce cas
est-ce que c'est l'heure où s y penser
l'heure de jouer des quatre ici
wafo princes 3
il est gonflé l'animal l'a appuyé on
prend variable plusieurs écoles ici je
peux faire qu'elle allait prendre 5
je peux faire des cinq aussi qu'elle
procède ça leur fort comme aime à les
cayes prend 1,5
puisque la tour attaque la dame je crois
que l'aller les noirs ont craqué complet
dames 1 damages quatre fers dame gcard
peut-être je vais aussi prendre tout
simplement et je prends tout simplement
je lui sortir mon cavalier calligé 5
je vais jouer d'hommes dans mes fins je
pense toutes les tenues ça va je vérifie
mais c'est bon dames et fun tout est
tenue puis alors maintenant l'autre tour
vont pouvoir venir ici aussi peut-être
et madame va venir en inde ou tanger
deux j'empêche la voile adam g 2 je
contrôle très bien ici je vais peut-être
contrôle je vais consolider avec sa
attention attention alors donc je pense
que par contre d'un match de il n'a pas
le choix un peu obligé des changes et
non parce que sur des objets 4 tôt j'ai
trois dom g4
c'est pas clair on va doubler
je joue ton g3 évidemment pour empêcher
les les problèmes ce cafouillage 3
simplement jour en f1
le cavaliere est attaqué alors
[Musique]
kf3 d'un machin al-khaleej 3
ça soit peu attention parce qu'il ya un
peu de pression quand même ici
tu reprends donc prendre tout simplement
entreprend on va prendre du web droit
ouais droit aux premiers rois et on joue
g3 au contrôle et lacazette 4
aujourd'hui quatre maintenant
25 secondes j'étais en train de regarder
le temps allez donc l' échec
on va prendre un g5 prise prise et on va
jouer trois chiens certainement on va
monter le roi encore une fois je crois
j'ai raté un match ok échec échec ou a
droit oui donc combat les ici maintenant
échec
on va la jouer tu fous là
très bien allez on va envoyer b4
maintenant à l'échangé pièce ça
m'arrange avec à 4 ok on va faire échec
échec des six c'est bon c'est facile à
gagner maintenant et chèques ils ont
joué 17 et c'est trop facile alors à
tour ses huit cavaliers chèque on prend
la tour et on va gagner tranquillement
bonjour 1 5 à 6 et c'est une victoire au
final voilà donc il fallait faire
attention parce que les noirs avaient
une pression quand même allé droit et il
fallait jouer des coups de défense
précis pour faire c'est changer le
matériel et sortir de là avec une pièce
de plus à 5 apparemment c'est une
préparation théorique pour jouer contre
toi aux dernières nouvelles peut-être
pourquoi pas
il reste une partie bonsoir à tous et
toutes à bon soir jérôme du bien c'est
jérôme donc on est dans le tournoi
suisse donc on a huit rondes quand il
joue il reste encore 5
il ya encore du chemin on pourrait sans
je suis 8e avec cinq et demi sur sur
huit un tournant très relevé et perdu 2
avec les noirs dans la même ouverture
d'ailleurs combine qu à chaque fois et
que j'ai perdu autant à chaque fois et
il y en avait une j'étais quand même pas
trop mal
voilà donc valide pas là ma façon de le
jouer je crois j'ai pas convaincu en
tout cas de non je pense pas que ça
valide la façon de jouer alors heureux
qu'à travailler je vais jouer avec des
cinq changer un peu d'un prend alors que
je vais te laisser 6,6
c'est bien ça roulait ont fait réfléchir
les blancs ça c'est bon c'est bon signe
c'est bon signe
alors vous c4 jouer avec l'a6 empêche
des caraïbes et 5 à 4 à 4 4 à 4 4
ouais non joués attend d'abord que les
c6 peut-être que ces 6
non
je joue avec eux 6
finalement
jean petit je voulais quatre camps
ce dernier un lit
des six
ah ça c'est ça permet de faire le fameux
fou proche de échec
ah oui simplement recul et on a tout
simplement affaibli le drap blanc on
revient recettes pour bien courir sur ce
ce petit clouage ça ça lâche une pièce
tempo les blancs peut craquer là alors
je fais tchèque d'abord ou pas leurs
biens échec à l'échec
maintenant qu'elle est des six pros le
mans là un petit rock devrait vous
satisfaire
voilà on est on est on est beaucoup
mieux puisqu'on a un pion en plus d'une
pièce alors j'ai envie de jouer 5 pour
voir le jeu de mon fou notamment de
venir en aide cinq salles il empêche pas
donc on va le faire
je peux je te laisser quatre là qu'elle
et ses 4 ne faut pas se précipiter à
prendre il faut réfléchir si vous n'avez
pas un coup intermédiaire ça c'est un
coup kathak la dame et une fois que
j'aurai pris ici dans prend il ya encore
une fourchette ici bon vous prend
cavaillé ou trois fourchettes ça finit
par faire cher à je peux prendre la dame
et prendre encore la tour je peux
prendre notre tour ok allez prise allez
hop
tour des six omlt être l'hôte retour on
va prendre ce pion des quatre tiendra
pas il est tout seul il est isolé
bon bah simplement doublé peut pas
prendre puisque voilà l'homme est joué
c'est tout simplement laisse aux clients
est perdu maintenant faut juste faire
attention évidemment mode du couloir bon
tour 17 on protège ses sets avant de
prendre il n'y a pas besoin de se
presser voilà que l'on prend on prend et
on a une grosse tour de plus plus tout
un tas de pions de plus h5 tour des
quatre on empêche le roi de d'avancé 3
jouée ces six skiffs écrit pions seront
entièrement défendu ce qui va libérer
notre hommage au geste comme ça en cas
d'échec je vais manger cette voie large
et 7
ces 6 no problemo no problemo aller tour
des trois attaques le pion pour d4
on prend on va venir en b 4
le tour des cinq on va le faire en
plusieurs étapes tour à 4
allez
hop et on va tout ramassé allées victor
des noirs ok bon on gagne soit très vite
très facilement
soit on perd au bout du bout du bout
autant une position compliquée ce soir
c'est stéphane à tort le rouleau
compresseur n'auront pas tout à fait un
ce que n'ont jamais perdu 2 quand même
beau et ça va six et demi alors au
niveau perf en est où
parce que maintenant comme le
pourcentage avait cessé un peu plus
significatif voilà c'est pas mal c'est
bien de 209 on va pas se plaindre c'est
bien ça va nous faire remonter un peu si
on continue
il nous reste quatre rondes il reste
quatre au hunan et quatrième pour
l'instant mais il ya des parties en
cours donc encore être 5e 6e
en tout cas cette chaise 68000 qui
cartonne chez 68000 en à un score contre
lui nul
on a fait une seule nul d'accord
superpower est-ce qu'on a un score face
à lui je sais pas
oui on mène 1 0 pakito femo en mène 13 à
pakito films ont il fait bon ton petit
au film il ya 2257 deux perfs as pas mal
tu en prennes se battre bien de faire
nul chez palais qui peut-être avec joe
bouchon c'est ça ouais c'est ça et il
reste super power qui joue là tiens on
va regarder sa partie
super power 51 moi il est beaucoup mieux
l'un alors là évidemment les noirs
peuvent pas prendre ici en a quatre
parce qu'il y aurait tour à sept avec
échec du fou et la tour ensuite ramasse
tranquille avec un traité jouer et ça
avance
voilà on peut gagner le fou donc
j'essaye tout reprend way autour des 7
vallées blanc une position assez
écrasante torts échec
ah oui il va pouvoir prendre le pion est
le cas tout en protégeant ici c'est
horrible ah oui ouhlala c'est horrible
c'est horrible pour super power mais il
n'y a pas besoin de jouer vite puisqu'il
n'ya pas de hockey et jouer donc qu'il
reste encore huit parties c'est cool la
tour est défendue par le fou des cinq
quand il pouvait peut-être subi
alors victor courcelles qui dit chat
likès fait gaffe liénard il est super
fort tu es turbet tueur beast allez je
regarde un peu dans le tournoi à six
parties
je ne m'arrêterai pas bloqués - qui
donne au masters jacoutot moto ou angie
franc 68e puis grand papy jonathan h 24
24 courjal ayasse et pauline sa peau
lynch s
qui joue elle a à la pelle ou trois
parties et la finul
elle n'a pas joué trois parties après
les turbines
pareil à la 2 qui n'a pas joué
apparemment c'est bizarre ça d'avoir des
trous comme ça
souvent et rousset soit au milieu soit
au début soit à la fin on sait en arrive
tard dans le tournoi bon on a d'être au
début soit on quitte tôt et on est trop
la fin c'est bizarre d'avoir des trous
au milieu
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont oublié que la
partie recommence et voilà et ils ont
perdu autant chez ba ba non non ce cas
là il aurait dû marquer zéro une
bizarrerie pourquoi j'ai voté à 5 à la
quatrième ronde il ya un problème sur le
temps qu'il faut absolument signalé
pakito fimo se prépare psychologiquement
contre diagonale tv eye fait bon
tournant alors un petit film où il a
sept points il est deuxième
il reste encore quatre ans quand même
donc encore largement de quoi
de quoi jouer
allez
c'est parti on joue face à vacquiers
68000 aller au lieu de quatre
réfléchis on a fait nul déjà donc
c'était quoi la partie qu'on avait joué
tiens j'avais lu blanc déjà le 6 juin et
des trois des cinq clés des deux mois je
veux que j'ai 3 pouces 2 2
du rock des 600 jeux théâtraux
ok
alors
toi c'est un coup je dois pouvoir se
jouer
h4 aussi d'un coup qui doit pouvoir se
jouer il m'a proposé nul je crois
la proposé nu le bougre tours 8
ok alors maintenant je trouve des coûts
maintenant c'est pas évident qu'il est
saint
bon il faut je crois qu'il faut prendre
ici
calais prend
je curieux quintaux calice et kachi pas
lequel est le mieux et j'aime bien calé
ses quatre ans je sais que les c4
l'homme 17
dames 17 oui
tu dis
17 il faut jouer à steph là sans jouer
[Musique]
dans une commune 15 là bas je tombais un
aller pour l'idée c'est que si je vous
faut et si j'ai pas je vais pouvoir
jouer sous 100 avant des problèmes jours
avec avec b2
tout simplement j'ai peut-être aussi
joué à troyes pour empêcher des cahiers
des 80 thuel hockey khl a peut-être
cavaliers 5
44 secondes comment ça commence à être
pénible
ça commence à être pénible cette
histoire
fawcett oui il faut s' est donc faux 7 x
7 x 7 mois joie 3 il faut commencer à
accélérer un peu allongé si ça affaiblit
un peu
donc c'est forcément une mauvaise
nouvelle et le four vient ok donc ici ou
à jouer fou d2 tout simplement pour
relier un peu nos nos tours opposition
est en train de se tendre un peu
b5 b6 nk simplement il faut de faire
reculer prise prises ailleurs
cela n'était pas prévu ça fait rien
qu'avec g4 son ca le temps maintenant
qu'on sait jouer
quel est roi il faut jouer il faut
attaquer d'un prend
cavalli hockey kf5 ccc un bon coup il
faut jouer d'am-dam l'a sans doute ici
attention parce qu'il y aura un échec là
d'accord donc l'a45 d'accord coalition
que je vous ai trois
quel et prend à pour prendre de la tour
obligé du roi on revient jeu qu'elle et
ses six tours 17 tours 17
vite vite vite on me jouer à 4 400
beaucoup je pense
laprise taurin on active notre tour ça
c'est pas mal oui donc ici le caillou 5
n'a proposé nul je rêve pas ainsi allez
je reprends sassine a fait ça pour me
perturber je suis sur ouette outre aux 4
b 3 je sais pas quoi faire du tout ici
toi
aïe aïe aïe aïe j'ai perdu un pied haut
encore ça va être ça va être difficile à
ici peut-être récupérer quelque chose
oui je récupère un peu mais pas beaucoup
d'autres plateaux rodez 3 3 voyez ça
c'est pas mal pour ces 4 août au top
c'est pas top top set ça c'est mieux
suite
à l'échec
toi et fuites pour la tour des 3 je
passe sur soi le mieux mais bon tant pis
non pas y acheter pas quoi faire ici roi
des deux taureaux 3 on est trois mois je
veux c'est 4 crise prises 1re 5 pts être
non se mange pas reda mais rien à faire
c'est perdu mais jouer et je crois qu'il
m'a proposé deux fois nulle en fait et
j'ai pas j'ai pas eu le temps de le voir
mais des fois c'est des trucs qui sont
ils fait exprès pour ce faire perdre du
temps et jouer
allez il reste encore trois parties
allez on joue face à jouer bouchon m6 je
vais changer par rapport à d'ailleurs je
vais pas jouer la famille même coup son
jeu que par ses trois bassins plan là
c'est bizarrement long le début
[Musique]
c'est bizarrement long le début alors
j'ai joué c'est pas le moment de perdre
du temps faute 4 qu'avec 17
six des huit donc je suis à six parce
que sur 2,8 il y avait les baissiers
embêté par contre et des scènes dont je
peux toujours prendre
allez on va prendre comme ça ok
[Musique]
ce 6
mam 7
alors cinq ici
ouais ça m'a l'air bien je fais fouet le
[Musique]
macadam voilà il a l'idée s'est cru et
en 17 tours des 8
touré 8 il faut reculer mon fou parce
que la cij avait reculé mon fou ils
échangent et les tours et à la fin je
perdais le pyongyang
tassé londres que j'aurais préféré mais
bon si ce n'est une autre fou sur cette
diagonale
ça me fera que les blancs d'oeufs triple
avec dam des deux c'est un peu poussif
tout ça mais bon tour des mythes
prend on prend à il peut faire frémir 5
ok mais ce que sur france3 d'en prendre
cinq tours promis france 3 pas mal il ya
menace de maths intermédiaire
ok comme g3
d'un prof ou g4 vous prendre prend on
apprend ces trois du coup pour coup j'ai
quatre autres anges 331
sinon je prends et je récupère ça chez
ça bouge et quatre fers tour des huit
vous prendrez un hockey qu'on ait un
rebond est très faible
ouais
cheikh 10 secondes 6
ça va là je crois oui c est ça va à
hasnon âgées pas vu dan franck
quelle erreur moi je perds tout pas du
tout vu dans prend m6 est pas nécessaire
en plus là j'ai pas besoin
s'ils jouent j en fait f6 ici 6 e 5 ha
mais je peux jouer d'un mètre 6 voilà
parce qu'elle soit d'en prendre un
projet change quand il faudra composer
je devrais pouvoir en sortir est par
contre si prendre du plomb c'est un peu
plus délicat au f 7 est bon la partie et
c'est ça notre mieux pour lui ce
continuer de mieux pour lui mme marois
est plus faible que le sien est joué bon
peut-être ma quatrième défaite là comme
il reste deux parties restent deux
parties
donc chez 68000 a fait une perf à 2500
il a perdu contre qui il a perdu face à
bigs zoppo s'agit nal plus tard et 3000
2351 superpower 51 2386 biggs au pot
2306 ah oui j'ai réfléchi un intrus
d'ailleurs j'étais en train de me dire
j'ai réfléchi à je me suis dit comme il
ya eu pas mal de joueurs français en
fait qu'ils sont arrivés avec le
confinement puisque la ffe a lancé les
tournois en ligne et où il ya eu 2000 je
dirais 2000 joueurs deux peut-être de
3000 joueurs difficile à dire mais qui
sont qui sont arrivés sur l'île sheth
dont beaucoup devaient jouer ailleurs je
pense et donc ils sont démarrés tous
avec mille cinq cents lots enfin pas
tous mais beaucoup d'entre eux disent on
ne jouait pas à vendre sur les chaises
ou peu vous n'avez pas joué depuis
longtemps et donc du coup on fait ces
joueurs qui valent beaucoup plus que
leur classement ils n'ont pas encore
atteint leur vrai classement alors
classement disons standard je me suis
dit salah par rapport aux derniers
résultats et donc le temps qui récupère
les points elo en force de jouer sur
lynch est ce parce qu'en fait si vous
voulez le transfert des points hauts il
n'est pas il est pas automatique au fsv
rssi pas immédiat si vous avez 1000
joueurs d'un coup 1500 joueurs qui sont
déjà fort parlant à 2000 2002 et qui
arrivent et qui démarra et mille cinq
cents lots ils vont prendre plein de
points aux autres joueurs et le temps
qu'ils atteignent leur véritable niveau
leach s
ça peut prendre un certain temps eh bien
ils ont un hello en dessous de leurs de
leurs de leurs valeurs de base quoi
comme c'est le cas pour les lois à eloi
legrand m et loire où l'enjeu lacarrau
joël l'équipe là pour une loi ça fait
pas très longtemps qui leur jolie chess
donc le temps qu'ils montent à son
niveau il a dû
ibis et où il a pris des points et comme
il a joué avec les français c'est les
français qui se prennent les points
entre eux donc pour l'instant ils ont
pas interagit beaucoup encore avec la
sphère extérieur au fil des mois ça va
se passer je pense à ce phénomène
voilà mes donc il se peut qu'il y ait
une poche comme ça de deux lots sous
valorisé c'est tout à fait possible
c'est une théorie un pur et j'ai pas
vérifié c'est difficile à vérifier comme
truc fort et faire un sondage
donc il reste deux parties bon il faut
essayer de finir en beauté quand même on
a quatre défaites mais face à des
joueurs bons bien classé bon c'est un
peu décevant quand même parce que je
mens sur ces niveaux là je dois pouvoir
gagner mais bon ça c'est mal ça s'est
mal goupillé réagit beaucoup les noirs
si j'ai l'impression regarde l'âge et
non les cellules non non moi j'avais les
noirs la javel et noir blanc et encore
les noirs que trois fois les noirs sur
les défaites sur les quatre défaites
j'ai eu trois fois les noirs web études
j'ai de bons résultats avec les normes
et critères mieux
sandales regarder les dates
d'inscription mais on peut le regarder
vous pouvez le regarder regarder les
profils des joueurs en ont regardé les
profils des joueurs oui vous allez voir
à partir de quand leur classement
commence à apparaître
parce que vous faites all time et vous
voyez bien si c'est depuis plusieurs
années qu'ils sont là où juste depuis
depuis un an ou deux et ça du coup ça
peut signifier qu' ils sont encore sous
valorisé 1 sur les pièces ça peut ne
sais pas c'est une théorie c'est pas ça
c'est une hypothèse plutôt alors plutôt
qu'une théorie si l'hypothèse aller aux
quatre ça lui est venue à l'esprit donc
c'est tout donc je partage l'idée quoi
des quatre qu'alexis
3 3 6 6 4 pendant qu'ils jouent mais
cinq cas regardez cette sorte que bien
des saveurs si je peux pas jouer cinq
prises prise le 5 allée des cinq à
l'écran
ce
non je joue c'est 4 je vous le coup me
parlent le mieux
je tape sur ftf cette chicane est parti
comme ça tu alors il me semble
par contre la seule toujours pas à
l'époque
b 6 ouais le ciss un bon coup touré faim
mc 7 on va jouer b3 pour mettre le fourn
les deux notes une partie comme ça tout
à l'heure
je sais je sais pas s'il va pas
simplement jouer qu'à le 8 mai c'est la
pression 1,5 et si je prends là il
reprend du cavalier ou du pion et à 5
alors en d2 ne s'est pas perdre trop de
temps allez on va prendre un à six alors
maintenant peut-être 5 ou des cinq noms
de ceux qui tentent ans je fais au 5 e
les 3 environ prend direct au quai
quelques niveaux
6 donc le fameux 6 alors là l'idée de 6
bon allez allez à ces trials 1 ces deux
cas c'est un peu le rock
pour cet objet de prendre ils pouvaient
ils pouvaient peut-être laissé le pion
aux yeux je sais pas je sais pas j'ai
pas si c'est mieux qu'à va laisser 5,5 à
6,5
on va prendre
jouer kg 5e leur d'être en bons coups
bas de la tour
bref si c'est pas mal non si je vais pas
faire d'am-dam c'est un ici pour éviter
damev 4 et pour voir libérer mon
cavalier 100 kb non là je peux bouger
mon terrier oui
cavalli la surca vallée prend 1,4 fou
prend un f6 attend
cavalli au capital et prend tout
problème si sûr tout proche pour
reprendre ici je fais çà ou là 19
secondes
heureusement que je vais à acheter alors
je peux pas faire le point ce système
est d'accord donc l'accabler prend quai
17 tu pouvais pas comprendre ce qu'ils
reprenaient du cavalier je vais le voir
en fait non c'est faux
allez vous prend cavaliers prend que le
ch et 5
dans me2
autour des 1 on active les tours au
maximum
ouais cavaliers kane 4,6 paletot
peut-être est resté muet ça fait rien
comme détroit
cadets 2 oui ok il veut le jouer comme
ça alors cavalli angers 4 échecs
de toi
très dur à défendre pour lui ça avait
voilà sapeurs la tour 9 secondes
on revient à sa perte ou la prends le 6
5 c'est terminé finito me prend finito
finito voilà merci à hook à titan du lin
finit par craquer sur la fin bron il
changeait alors ici en fait c'est je
pense c'est le les changes de la dame
contre les deux tours ici c'est pas top
pour plein de raisons
1 c'est qu'il ya des faiblesses parce
qu'il ya trois îlots chez les noirs
contre 2 chez les blancs avec donc un
endroit qui est un peu faible et surtout
il ya aussi dames et cavaliers alors là
le le duo dames et cavaliers c'est
extrêmement puissant en attaque voilà et
comme en plus ces pièces sont un peu
éclaté il ya des thèmes là un peu
partout de pour récupérer des pions et
n'est donc parfois c'est une bonne idée
d'échangé la dame comprenait deux tours
mais là en l'occurrence c'est pas le
type d'opposition ou c'est bon
et hugo qui nous dit qu'ils remontent à
l'est reste une partie alors essayer de
finir en beauté on a sept et demi pour
l'instant sur sur 12 on est 12e tournant
est très relevée comme d'habitude 88
joueurs
donnez aussi avoir le fait que le
[Musique]
suicide ne s'est pas le berserk ses
adversaires qu'il ya des tournants arena
classique lychees faut jouer vite pour
enchaîner les parties
du coup la plus d'erreurs aussi et du
coup c'est possible que effectivement
les performances soient pas de même
nature dans les roues dans l'entrevue
cession des joueurs qui sont plus à
l'aise dans ce type de formule que dans
l'autre à l'ecal et m6 ont joui des 5,5
2006 ouais problème ici on va prendre
ici maintenant je vais fouiller 4 d'un
train d'attaquer violemment les cases
noires l'un puisque ici on attaque voilà
moi je le prends parce qu en fait voilà
ça me permet d'attaquer tout de suite le
le pion ici
concept
dans ces huit au coin ça va être la tour
face à ce pion peut-être pas de prendre
ainsi quand je commence à regretter un
peu vite mais bon je m'en sortir
maintenant avec
allez faut cette marocaine
[Musique]
damas six
puis tour des huit dames 10 8 je suis
l'un des huit mois je n'aurais pas dû
prendre direct tu vas mieux à faire pour
s'imposer je vais vous pouvez prendre un
petit un petit truc sympa bon et
agissent pour empêcher ou g5
mais pour des 6 1
ça c'est bien ça me prend
ça va là j'ai récupéré un fou
ça va
alors b4 b4 bkb 4 qu'est ce qu'on va
faire sur b4 ce que je peux jouer 5
oui aux gens un par an tu fais pas mal
être mais ce que je joue ça quand même
tac ouais sainté
juhasz m
que j'attaque la dame ok
attention ils m'attaquent le pion je
jouais b6 pas besoin d'un pion 6éme pion
à 16 mais là bon donc on n'y a pas de
une spéciale il faut pas il faut pas
donner des pions gratuit quand même au
hockey on peut qu'elle admire détroit
sans doute m² en d4 qui est pas mal
si je prends je peux aussi jouer
cavalier le cadre derrière ses 4,2 me
prend
pas les tours 8 attention on est en
train de cette seconde contre une 01
commencé à accélérer un peu mc5 alors
dame ces cinq dames c5 qu'avec trois
écueils aux quatre petites pressions ici
dans le cinq
je me laisse peut-être cavaliers prend
c3 puisque dame prend il pas possible
tout reprend d'un prend cavaliers car il
prend ses trois oui ça a l'air de
marcher quelles pensées trop valeur de
marché ne me prend hélas erreur échec
je vais anticipé celui-là bon on va
finir en beauté la tour prends pas
j'aurais pu faire un échec que tu fais
un petit échec intermédiaire ça mange
pas de pain et là on et voilà on échange
la dame c'est bon on va les manger tous
les pions et moi pousser tranquillement
[Musique]
aller aux wc le matin même un peu avec
des échecs
parce qu'on peut chaque échec un échec
c'est bon on check et échec et mat
bon ben c'est pas trop mal merci à l'aib
et donc c'était la troisième partie
c'est pas mal on a gagné la dernière
alors on fait une perf à 2178 c'est bien
on a perdu 4 tout quatre façades et plus
de 2200 et dont trois fois avec les
noirs bon et dont on aurait pu faire un
peu mieux on aurait pu faire un peu
mieux en gagner une de plus c'était
remisage abl au moins mais bon c'est
quand même pas mal
c'était on attend qu'on a réussi réussi
un bon tournoi
alors que shell 68000 il joue face à
djenane schiste est angoissé dewar la
partie chaise 68800 je vous fais ça
génial chess alors qu'est ce qui s'est
passé donc prend à y avait cabinet fuite
qui faisait une fourchette
c'est dommage ouais ça marche pas des
masses puisque le fou contrôler la case
ouais ça ne marche pas non plus
et victoire de gnl chess ouais il a raté
un truc là ne joue un peu vite sans
doute puisque ici qu'elle les prend
c'est bizarre moi ici tourcoing sans
doute pas mal parce que la tour est
coincé de toute façon on était enfermé
regardez comme la tour ici étant fermés
peut pas aller en dix-sept n'ira 6 à
cause du fou qui contrôle tout donc
aller perdu sept tours donc tout
reprendre 17 pourquoi pas hélas hélas il
y avait un joli coup il y avait
cavaliers fuite fourchette et la tour
peut pas venir défendre le fou le fou
peut venir défendre la tour mais
récupéré la tour c'est pas mal et après
il ya deux pions passé lié on s'est
peut-être perdant mais c'est pas facile
a encore gagné
c'est pas facile à gagner pour les noirs
à cause de ses deux pions pas scellier
qui veillera au centre bon aya restait 8
c'est fini alors victoire de finale de
sa ginals tue pas sashina tu pas qu'il
ya deux défaites et et pas mal de
victoires donc avec une match nul à la
fin pas mal avec une perf à 2389 un très
bon tournoi pour sa finale tu n'as tu
fais 68800 réalise lui aussi un très bon
tournoi avec 2426 deux perfs deux
défaites deux nuls général caisse fini
troisième avec 2253 deux perfs et trois
défaites et une nulle à il a une âme il
est arrivé en retard il a même bâiller
au début il a une nulle au lieu d'avoir
une défaite d'accord ok il ya le baiia
inclus dans le truck reste pas mal jay
21 n 2 finit lui aussi avec une grosse
perf à 2321 et 2 défaites 1 2 3 4 nuls
ok je le push ont donc joué bouchons
fini avait 2264 deux perfs et puis donc
un deux trois défaites et trois nuls
n'aurait très prat fini avec une perf à
2136 et quatre défaites et une nulle
c'est bien 2289 pour y
hh j on a joué avec lui je crois non non
il a quatre défaites et une nulle
bravo pakito fimo qui fait un bon
tournoi aussi fait une perf à 2195 et
donc il a un deux trois défaites et
trois nuls
ok et donc je finis avec une perf à 2178
quatre défaites une mule
c'est mieux que dernière fois en tout
cas et biggs au pot fini avec quatre
défaites et deux nuls pour les voilà
pour les dix premiers 88 joueurs c'était
pas mal ouais c'est bien
iv 66 comment ton franc 68e ont gâché ce
king hockey comme papy stéphane damien
denechaud turbie stature biste d'aguilat
pas je vous la fais un parement il a pas
joué absent alors il a été absent dans
le tournant c'est dommage il avait
commencé pas mal là où il a fait 3 et 3
victoires 3 3 défaites
allez continuez donc pour jacques politi
sans doute qu'ils pareils était absent
au début sans la faire jouer quelques
parties seulement l'a pas vu que c'était
un suisse sans doute
on va tous bravo à tient à david david
2b 78 pas mal parce qu'il a presque tout
jouer il sait bien il ya eu débat y
passe qu'il a oui d'accord il a tout
joué s'est accroché à il a tout perdu
mais il s'est accroché jusqu'au bout
bravo parce que c'est pas évident de
rester motivé quand on perd les
participants le tournoi relevé un s'il
faut faut pas vous décourager le
tournant est très fort si vous voulez
faire des tournois leach est ce vous
avez la possibilité
regardez dans l'it sheth vous allez dans
la dans les tournois ici tournoi à
rennes tournoi donc à rennes standard
vous avez des tournois spéciaux réservés
au moins 2500 vélos voyez moins de 1500
à rennes de bull est rapide et même de l
orbite
voilà réserver au moins 2500 donc si
vous voulez jouer avec des joueurs de
votre niveau à les îles à quoi allait
jouer des arènes de moins de mille cinq
cents lots vous s'amuserait beaucoup
plus si vous voulez marquer des points
parce que c'est vrai que là le niveau
quand même assez élevé il faut avouer
et puis il ya des arènes à moins de 1700
ont donc et moins de 2000 voyez donc
c'est quand même pas mal quoi il ya de
quoi réserver des tournois
des joueurs sur des plages et l'eau
c'est bien donc voilà donc si vous êtes
débutant vous voulez pas perdre trop de
partis quand même ça sert à rien de
jouer contre des joueurs trop fort parce
que vous apprendrez pas beaucoup qu'on
ne reprendrait pas pourquoi vous perdez
il vaut mieux jouer des joueurs un peu
plus fort que vous mais pas trop fort
donc typiquement 200 300 points de plus
voilà ça suffit 200 300 points au delà
c'est pas la peine
moi j'ai 2178 j'ai été jusqu'à 2003 moi
je savais sert à rien je joue contre les
2006 sait déjà c'est déjà presque trop
2006 2007 c'est trop 2005 je peux
accrocher des parties des fois mais 2004
ça va je peux je dois m'accrocher
régulièrement ça m'arrive mais mai 2006
2007 2008 et au delà c'est pas la peine
en fait je suis très content si je
rencontre c'est pas la question mais si
je rencontre que des joueurs de ce
niveau là je vais finir par m'ennuyer
je fais voilà ce que c'est des pros au
quasiment c'est tous des grands maîtres
donc c'est leur métier il faut ça tout
le temps moi je joue pas tout le temps
ok perso je joue classique mensuelle
tous les mois il ya un bouclier a gagné
27 400 c'est encore possible
2400 2410 2406 jouable 2005 ça commence
à être vraiment vraiment délicat
et a26 c'est trop c'est trop pour moi
après ça dépend pour qui mel a admis si
c'est des grands maîtres sont voilées m
sont classés 2004 2005 sur les fesses ce
qui est le classement normal de m donc
les pièces seront les lots sont quand
même proche de l'oréal et peut avoir des
grosses différences mais dans l'ensemble
en moyenne c'est assez proche
c'est relativement proche on va dire dur
dur le tournoi pour paquito ouais merci
pour le like the way c'est cool donc
alors qu'est ce que je peux vous dire
que vendredi choix sans doute ce que
j'ai fait la semaine dernière je serai
du jeu libre le vendredi parce que je
trouve c'est pas mal le vendredi après
midi
c'est avant le week-end souvent il ya
les jeunes qui sortent de l'école voilà
qui sont un peu tranquille donc c'est un
créneau que j'ai envie d'occuper pour
l'instant crée donc je vais réserver
pour le club à la rentrée si ça reprend
normalement mais en attendant je ferai
du jeu libre le vendredi après midi
il s'agit sage inalp et une à qui veux
me faire un bullet avec moi aller chaque
set parce qu'il est de 1400 au cas où je
peux gagner des points
allez il me propose un but un petit
bullet pour terminer
moi je finis par sarah parce que j'ai
pas mangé il faut les manger quand même
concept
nice
tout est à moi il faut il faut il faut
pas que je traîne hop hop hop valait 17
ouais aujourd'hui tu comprends que ces
six 36 31 attention on risque la grèce
se montait à l'efo six voitures de métro
secoue la safranière fuite tout une
seconde
attention est capable d'accélérer
l'abruti de leucate kbc 3 eyes
il a commencé à me piquer un pion mais
silva m'ont piqué à m impliquer d'autres
il joue très très vite attention alma
piquer un cavalier sais c'est mal ça
horrible et parce que cinq secondes
ouais bravo
mais après ils jouent très très vite moi
je sais pas le fait en bullet ça non non
je vais arrêter là
merci merci pour le bullet ok donc on
finit là dessus très bon tournoi
on va tous très relevé donc je finis 9e
avec donc 2178 de père c'est pas mal
quatre défaites faire un peu mieux
peut-être mais c'est quand même pas mal
et donc bravo au trio wenger donc sage
inhalt une à 16 68 milles et jean hachey
ce qu'ils ont fait un très gros tournois
donc rendez-vous à vendredi pour ceux
qui veulent faire un peu de jeu libre
sinon ça me dit peut-être un tournant je
sais pas on va voir
et puis d'ici là bon bout s'ils ont bien
joué je lancerai live oubliez pas dans
la description si vous voulez être au
courant des larmes quand je lance de
vous abonner à diagonale tv la chaîne i
mean you échec la chaîne et twitch si
vous avez si vous aimez twitch vous
pouvez aussi me suivre sur twitter
ciao ciao saluer pilote mng salut
anthony 3d saluer paquito salut tout le
monde